[Music]  build trees the vehicles not safe  we need to fail need to fail down here  so we don't fail up there you know  everyone's in agreement we'd like you to  command  [Music]  well what's wrong nothing honey  it has done to the moon  - yeah  the entire world's watching hi do you  question whether the program's worth the  cost in money in a month one of the  chances do not coming back or those tips  they don't have a father anymore great  so you're gonna sit the boys down and  you're gonna prepare them for the fat  you might not ever come home why do you  think you're coming back  we've got this under control you're a  bunch of boys you don't have anything  under control  [Music]  [Music]